alors que le chômage s'envole ces
derniers mois atteignant les 7 % dans
les yvelines des entreprises
industrielles recruter peine à trouver
des collaborateurs l'antenne pôle emploi
cadres de guyancourt a décidé de
profiter de la semaine de l'industrie
pour organiser ce jeudi un rendez vous
afin de cibler au mieux les besoins de
ces sociétés
au programme analyse conjointe des cv et
explications dans le détail des
compétences recherchées l'antre on
travaille sur quasiment de la dentelle
ou les recrutements sont plus
compliquées en drive par des approches
de compétence on travaille aussi avec
les employeurs pour rechercher d'autres
profils pour les profils seniors ou des
profils un peu moins qualifiés exemple
avec ce recruteurs venus pour le compte
d'une société informatique dont la
croissance serait en moyenne de 20% par
an simplement on a du mal à trouver du
mal à trouver les bonnes compétences que
ce soit au niveau commercial puisque
nous recrutons des chargés d'affaires et
aussi au niveau technique nous
recherchons peut-être plus des moutons à
cinq pattes c'est peut-être un petit peu
la difficulté
impossible encore de dresser le bilan de
l'opération mais un constat déjà il
faudra multiplier à l'avenir ce genre
d'opération maintenant le pôle emploi à
une cvthèque diffuse des annonces des
annonces qui sont qui sont
systématiquement renouvelés
donc c'est vraiment important de
d'être présent et d'établir ce
partenariat j'insiste mais c'est
vraiment important